hi this is mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to to another math video
to help you boost your score in your
math class improve your understanding
and hopefully make learning math a lot
less stressful so we're going to talk
about in this video is how to find the
greatest common factor and the least
common multiple now students sometimes
get these a little bit confused and
teachers have different ways of
explaining it but let me show you a way
that makes sense to me and hopefully
will make sense to you too so what we're
going to do is we're gonna look at these
two terms 2x cubed Y to the fourth and
16 X Y squared now what I recommend is
do a prime factorization tree so you
want to break down the number so you can
see what the number is composed of what
it's made up of so we can see that this
is going to be 2x cubed Y to the fourth
right 16 is going to be 4 times 4 which
can be broken down to four tues which is
2 to the 4th X to the first y squared
okay just to show you that X cubed
there's 3 x's for wise but I would
normally just write this as 2x cubed Y
to the fourth and two to the fourth XY
squared now when you're finding the
greatest common factor okay this may
come as a little bit of us and irony
here you actually want to take whatever
occurs the least so even though it's the
greatest common factor you want to take
whatever occurs the least so here we
have 12 here we have four twos our
greatest common factor GCF is just going
to start off with two to the first now
we've got 3 x's 1 X we only are going to
use 1 x and y to the 4th + y squared
really going to use Y squared so what
the greatest common factor tells us is
this is the largest quantity that will
divide into this quantity and into this
quantity it's the largest it's the
greatest but if we were to pick let's
say instead of 1 X 3 axes like X cubed
this would be too large it wouldn't go
into or divide into this quantity evenly
what it would have too many x's so
that's why you're actually doing the
opposite you're choosing whatever occurs
the least okay now as far as the least
common multiple the least common
multiple use this technique when you're
trying to get common denominators like
say you're trying to add one third and
115th you know you're trying to find the
smallest denominator so that these both
have the same denominator so you can add
them together now when you find the
lowest common denominator or in this
case we're talking about the least
common multiple what you actually do is
you take whatever occurs the most right
so it's the opposite right it's ironic
so here we have 12 here we have four
twos so for our least common multiple
we're actually going to need for tues
here we've got three X's 1x we're going
to need the one that occurs the most
three and we have four wise and 2 y's
we're going to need the one that occurs
the most now you can go ahead and
simplify this this is going to be 16 x
cubed Y to the fourth so what that means
is that if this was our denominator and
this was our denominator this is what we
would want to be our common denominator
okay so that's the lowest quantity that
this will be able to go into evenly as
well as this will be able to divide into
evenly so just think about the opposite
greatest common factor actually take
whatever occurs lasts ok and the least
common multiple take whatever occurs
most so see if you can do this one on
your own if you want pause the video and
you can restart it and see if you got it
right but let's dive right in so
basically 48 is 8 times 6 i'm just doing
a prime factorization tree for x 2 to x
3 4 is 2 times 2 so we have four twos 13
1 x + 3 y's right 60 x we have 6 times
10 2 x 3 notice i just keep dividing
these breaking these down until they're
only divisible by 1 and themselves so
their prime numbers and i write them in
order from lowest to highest for this
one we have two squared three to the
first five to the second and one x okay
so if we want to find the greatest
common factor the GCF okay let's see so
greatest common factor we have to take
whatever occurs less we've got two twos
here for tues here we only are going to
use two twos we have 13 13 to tie what
are you do in the case of a tie you just
use one okay and then we have one x + 1
x okay which we are just going to take
whichever cruise-less that's x we've got
two fives
and no five so we definitely need to
know 5s okay we take whatever occurs
less and we've got Y cubed and no y
cubed so we're going to just take no y
cubed okay so we're taking whatever
occurs less so if you simplify this you
get 12x and that's the greatest common
factor so that means that 12 X is the
largest thing that will divide into 60 x
5 x + 12 X will divide into is the
largest thing they will also divided
into 48 X Y cubed so if you were trying
to like reduce 60 x / 48 X Y cubed if
you divided the numerator in the
denominator x 12 x okay this will allow
you to reduce the fraction to lowest
terms so this would give you five this
is going to give you four Y cubed so now
it's reduced so that's the largest
quantity that goes into both of these
okay least common multiple least common
multiple we're actually going to take
whatever occurs more so here we have
four twos tutus we're going to need for
tues 1313 it's a tie so we're still
going to use 1325 s no fives we're going
to use 25 I usually go from lowest to
highest X's we've got 1 X in both cases
so it's a tie and then y cubed nowise
we're going to take the one that occurs
more y cubed so if we simplify all that
down what do we get we get let's see so
that's going to be 16 times 3 is 48 x 25
okay let's see we've got some tough math
here ok let's see 48 x 25 what is that
well we've got 5 times 8 is 40 carry the
4 that's 20 20 40 60 61 that's eight
nine so we're getting let's see what is
it 00 1200 so we're basically getting
1200 X Y cubed and that's your least
common multiple so I hope this helped
you understand how to find a greatest
common factor in these kind of multiple
faster and easier just think of doing
the opposite okay and check out some my
past videos subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you in the next video I'll talk
to you soon